[Music]  a mythical monster straight out of your  worst nightmares with wildlife in a  hideous face and feet that were  amazingly freakishly  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  Wow look at all this stuff this is the  most beautiful miracle I've ever seen it  Ralph breaks the Internet thank you like  me how in your universe there's only one  spider-man  but there's another universe it looks it  sounds like yours but it's not hey guys  okay who are you i'm gwen stacy people  are there something new what is it up to  no but that beat is pretty fresh  [Music]  [Music]  it's like it knows our every move weird  right  [Music]  we did it the world's first dragon  Viking utopia he's not the only one  light fury I've hunted every Night Fury  except yours and him over I will never  give him up it's you and me bud Oh  [Music]  [Music]  you might  I wonder in Wonderland  [Music]  [Music]